[Music]
on this sunday night the new covet 19
variant confirmed in two provinces
what we're learning about its origin and
its spread
it's pretty much entrenched it's going
to be with us will the vaccines help
protect us against this new variant
holiday horror at an ontario long-term
care home
39 deaths this week alone that is an
atrocity
a hospital takes over as coveted case
numbers and the death toll rises
lucky lost and found confirmed
two subjects the new technology that
saved two lives on a rescue
training run
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
colleen christie good evening thanks for
joining us we begin tonight with
more confirmed cases of the new variant
of covet 19 in canada
this afternoon health authorities in
ottawa announced a case there and now a
confirmed case in bc
all of the cases are now linked to
travel but health experts believe
community spread of this new highly
contagious variant
is inevitable abigail beeman has our top
story tonight
this is now just the tip of the iceberg
it's it's pretty much entrenched
it's going to be with us while there are
only a few confirmed cases of the uk
variant in canada
experts believe there are likely more
genome sequencing to
find it doesn't happen automatically
with every covet 19 test
ontario is now ramping up sequencing
dramatically
we tested less than 10 percent of the
positive cases to date
but we expect to be at much higher
numbers very shortly
the new cases in ottawa and vancouver
island involved individuals who returned
from the u.k
and ontario now says the two cases east
of toronto
did have contact with a uk traveler
contrary to what they said
saturday there certainly are a lot of
unanswered questions
there is no evidence the new strain is
more deadly nor
causes a worse illness the general
consensus is that
it's probably a bit more transmissible
it's just not quite clear
how much more this is a perfect curve
ball
for our attempts to control the pandemic
the scientific director of ontario's
covet 19 advisory science table says
a virus that's even a little more
contagious could pose a big problem
peter uni wants everyone to follow the
rules a new province-wide lockdown
kicked in
saturday even ten percent means that we
need to do even more restrictions to
keep this
sort of under control and we know
already how much we struggle right now
we need to take that
very seriously something experts are
tracking
carefully you may have heard of the
spike protein this virus is like a
little ball
but it has these these molecules of
protein
which are like little spikes that are
stick up on the surface
they make it easier for the virus to
attach to the cell
it needs the spike protein to get into
our cells and cause an
infection in us it's also the part of
the virus that the
vaccine is designed to target
it has a lot of mutations in the spike
protein seven changes but the spike
protein is pretty long and so there's
still a lot to recognize
the consensus is the new variant won't
have an impact on the vaccine's
effectiveness but more research is
underway
and so is more sequencing to figure out
how many cases exist in canada
and how long they've been here colleen
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks abigail
hundreds of trucks are still
stranded at the english port of dover
trying to cross the channel into france
they've been stuck for days because of
new travel restrictions in place
due to the new covet variant mass
testing programs are helping ease the
backlog but delays are expected to
continue
through the week mass vaccinations have
finally begun
across the european union
from france to finland the eu has begun
its official vaccination program for its
450 million residents
the coordinated effort aims to ensure
the vaccine rolls out fairly to all 27
countries in the block
but some europeans have expressed
frustration as the pfizer biontech
vaccine developed in germany
has been distributed to other countries
first
and horrific covet 19 outbreak in an
ontario long-term care home
has led to the deaths of 41 seniors over
the christmas
weekend the outbreak is now being
managed by a local hospital authority
but as morgan campbell reports families
are speaking out asking for military
assistance like ontario and quebec had
last spring
they are heart heart-wrenching images to
take in as a family gathers on the front
lawn of this long-term care home
east of toronto pleading for help as
tender care living center grapples with
a major
outbreak of the novel coronavirus she's
tested positive for coved
and she's scared she's isolated she's
mentally unstable
this is jessica wong's grandmother jean
a strong
willed happy woman who loves socializing
and
peanut butter sandwiches she is one of
128 residents
and 69 staff members diagnosed with
kevit 19.
over the christmas break 41 residents
have died from the disease north york
general hospital
is now managing the outbreak which they
believe
is connected to community transmission
the company that runs the home is
looking to recruit
additional staff writing in a statement
tender care
has been hit hard by the virus and as a
result a significant number of staff are
infected
and have been forced to isolate we have
reached out to the surrounding hospitals
ontario health and staffing agencies for
additional resources to support resident
care
advocacy groups have been sounding the
alarm as the
industry continues to see escalating
numbers of homes battling
similar outbreaks something has to
change government needs to sever its
connection with the industry policy
needs to be made in the public interest
not in the interests
of the industry would make sense if this
level of carnage was happening equally
in all of the homes
but it isn't and ownership matters and
the
worst and most devastating outbreaks
have consistently been
in these for-profit facilities and the
data doesn't lie
the home maintains infection prevention
and control education
are well underway but families with
loved ones behind these walls say
they want to see more done which means
adding additional staff right away
and potentially bringing in military
resources
we need more transparency and
communication
with the home itself and with the
families
and we need the government to take
action morgan campbell global news
toronto authorities say a person of
interest in the christmas day explosion
in nashville
died in the blast investigators now say
tissue found at the site
is from the remains of anthony quinn
warner police and federal agents have
spent two days
scouring for clues at a suburban home
linked to warner
a google street view image of the
address shows an rv
similar to the one police believe was
used in the bombing
investigators say they don't believe
anyone else was involved in the attack
and are still trying to determine a
motive
coming up next timely technology how a
training run becomes a rescue mission on
a b.c
mountain
britain is being battered by a powerful
storm tonight
storm bella is packing hurricane-force
winds of up to 170 kilometers an hour
and
lots of rain the weather system is
causing widespread flooding across the
u.k
leaving dozens of drivers stranded train
service has been disrupted in several
parts of england
across the channel in france nearly all
of the country is under storm warnings
in iran a series of avalanches have
killed at least
12 people state tv is reporting several
other people are missing
rescue teams are now searching a
mountainous area north of tehran for
survivors
the slides happened on friday after the
region was hit by snowfall and powerful
winds
the mountain range is popular on
weekends for hiking and climbing
the holiday season is a popular time to
head to the mountains but a growing
number of canadians are getting into
trouble on local hills
forcing rescue teams into action one bc
volunteer group has had a
record-breaking year
as julia foy explains the team recently
saved the lives of two hikers
ones they weren't even looking for some
something miracle you know it's
happening to us that this is
unbelievable
these two hikers aren't the only ones
who think something very special
happened in the mountains near vancouver
just days before christmas and the fact
that you know we found them
an hour before they were even reported
missing i think is
incredible it's a pretty lucky day the
rescue happened in vancouver's north
shore mountains
volunteers were having a training
session with new night vision goggles
north shore rescue is the first
volunteer rescue group in canada
to have them
no one expected to find anyone in
trouble but suddenly
they could see something in the darkness
we spotted
a light low down we all kind of looked
at each other and just thought
what like is this for real this can't be
happening we have nowhere to go
can go up can go down there's a cliff
under us
and we are sitting in the water within
minutes the helicopter crew managed to
drop
food warm clothes and a radio and a
ground
team was sent in to get them out for
these two individuals being trapped
on a waterfall soaking wet they've been
out since 9 30 in the morning
this was a worst case scenario for them
since the pandemic more canadians are
heading outdoors and that's led to more
people hiking and snowshoeing in the
back country
for north shore rescue this operation
was a record breaker
the 146th of the year more than
any previous years before the use of
night vision technology
it could have had a very different
ending we would not have found them
that night based on the location they
were in so they
potentially could have succumbed to
hypothermia this week is traditionally
one of the busiest times of year for the
rescue team in bc and they urge
anyone heading outdoors to be prepared
we're asking people to exercise
caution if you're going into the back
country make sure
you have your avalanche safety equipment
you know how to use it
as for craig and peter they know how
lucky they were to survive
these guys are really like angels you
know happening see us and then rescued
us
right there and they're really fast
julia foy global news
still ahead an artist of sorts who works
in snow
and sends his fans downhill
you're watching global national
former montreal expo's pitcher and
broadcaster derek
coyne has died from brain cancer a
family statement said the native
quebecer
left peacefully surrounded by love
saturday night
a coin joined the expos organization in
1989 making his major league debut
in 1996. he went on to become a tv and
radio sports analyst
he was inducted into the quebec baseball
hall of fame last year
months after being diagnosed with cancer
a coin
was 50 years old it's been said if you
find a job you love to do you'll never
work a day in your life
well that is certainly the case for one
alberta man he traded in childhood play
for a grown-up passion
and as kami kepke reports in the process
he's bringing a lot of fun
to a lot of people this winter nestled
high in the mountains of banff national
park
ben cyrillic is living out a childhood
dream i spent many hours in the sandbox
as a kid and then as i got older i
started building
train park features in my backyard and
figured out that that was my passion now
he's swapped buckets and sand for heavy
machinery and tons of snow
cyrelic is in charge of designing
building and of course
testing out sunshine village's five
terrain parks
what makes a great terrain park is
having a well-balanced progression
throughout the training so you know you
want to make sure you have those
stepping stones for the beginners
because they're going to improve and
become your advanced riders
it's also key to keep things fresh the
park crew revamps the runs every few
weeks to make sure they're keeping
everyone
including the locals on their toes
people don't want
kind of the same setup every season they
don't want the same setup every
month they're just fine you can really
improve on them and
you just feel really cool when you're
riding them like they really got to put
some thought into how they build them
and
make it so everyone can ride them they
do an awesome job of it here
it's just it just flows so smoothly
sorella can work surprisingly fast
once he mapped out this feature it took
less than an hour to build and shape the
bulk of a 40-foot jump
and put a rail in place so i try and do
most of the heavy lifting with the snow
cats so we'll lift the rail into place
bury it with the cat and i'll try and
shape it as clean as possible with the
cat
an analogy i like to use the snow cats
like the lawn mower and park crew
have the weed whackers 2020 has seen
near record-breaking snow on the
mountain and the great divide park has
had its earliest ever opening
the chance to enjoy the outdoors is a
silver lining and a tough year for many
people
and cyrillic hopes to make it that much
better for those on the hunt for big air
or their first jumps kami kepke
global news
a sky-high celebration for all to see a
pilot in germany took to the skies last
week tracing the shape of a syringe
ahead of today's european rollout of the
coveted 19 vaccine
pilot sammy kramer said he thought it
would be a fun and unconventional way to
raise awareness that the vaccine
has arrived and that is global national
for this sunday night i'm colleen
christie
tonight's your canada is this harbor in
dildo newfoundland and labrador
email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching far nasser will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow
have a great night
you